welcome to the double tournament feature
here in st. Louis called the 2014 st.
Louis Invitational in the top tournament
players will compete in a very strong
field to try to become grandmasters
they're also playing for a large prize
fund in our second tournament lower
titled players will compete with
international masters to try to become
international masters or IMS in our
first decisive game today chess club
resident Grandmaster Josh free dell was
able to defeat Webster University's
dennis burroughs game I mean okay I
wanted to kind of play solid in the
first round and kind of see what people
were up to and just see like I wasn't
sure how he'd approached the game
whether he'd really play ambitiously or
whether he'd you know I figured he'd try
to throw me off my preparation somehow
so I just kind of played something a
little unusual for me but Tom but it
ended up I think she just didn't know
the opening very well so he but he'll
use the plots of time and played a
little bit with a little too much risk
at me ok these b6 I usually play six but
b6 of courses it's fun so we transpose
after a three we transpose into a normal
system but here most people take on g5
there are other moves as well you can
play what he played I think is a move as
well but taking on d5 followed by night
takes or he takes this most common oh
yeah the turning point I'd say was in
this position where he took and played
queen bee three this is a typical idea
but I thought that because a3 is
basically a waste of the temple it was a
little bit provocative and then in this
position I think he should play III and
just kind of play Bishop e2 get castle
though when he played rook do you wanna
I really had a lot of ambitions because
I thought that he was a little too
provocative he's not close to developing
his King side so I had to play
ambitiously with c5 and okay after this
i mean i think his position is already
very unpleasant maybe he has a way to
get an objectively more or less okay
position but I felt like already I was
the one playing
for advantage and then the big moment
was afternoon 86 d 5 10 and there's kind
of a nasty trick which is that after
Queen takes d5 I can take on b2 and
Queen takes d7 loses the bishop check
and his Queen won't fall so his king is
basically just way too open and he's not
developed and after this i mean okay i
think his position is just bad 95 like
all the end games I just win his Queen
side and his Kings still can't develop
so here I had the option actually to
sack my queen with quite XD one which I
had a feeling might be winning but I
didn't actually see the winner after
check 9 a-4 and then II for to give his
Kings breathing room and okay i have
many tempting options but i didn't see
anything super clear and I felt like
this wasn't necessary so as fun as it
would have been I just decided to play
Queen c7 and I think that the last
moment it was his his opportunity to
play 94 and now okay I thought like at
the very least I can take check now I
was thinking about even Queen c2 but
Queen takes be too also is probably a
big advantage for black maybe not as
winning so super easily um but it looked
very unpleasant but I think he had to do
this because after he played Bishop a 6
I think he blundered so in this position
if he cancels when I play Knight c3 and
he asked the movies Queen and I just win
his Bishop if he takes on d1 then I have
several options i think i was planning
Queen takes CA with the idea that if
King e2 I can play Queen a6 check and
his king is just stuck in the center for
no compensation probably losing and
after Bishop f5 then I have this nasty
moving i take c 3 which he missed I
think and then the point is if i take
the night then queen see one checks so
at this point he's basically losing i
mean no keep taking on h7 just loses
immediately but i think that already
objectively is just completely lost so
um so yeah I mean I think he got a
little ambitious with this Queen B
through roof d1 and then he okay maybe
he had a chance to get like I'm much
worse too lost in game but it's it's
already very unpleasant so six and a
half points does the trick it'll get you
what you came here for seven players in
this field looking for their grandmas
norm in the second field the IM norm
section former st. Louis in' arun sharma
the former chess club and scholastic
center champion Iskandar arup off you
just have to take it one game at a time
and do your best and I mean that being
said give in like this is around robbing
you know what score you need that can't
affect like you know how far you think
you want to push in a particular game
especially like later in the tournament
how badly you might need a win or if a
draw is good for your good for your
standing or not he played this move
Queen a 5 which I know has been played
before but is not certainly the most
standard move and I didn't really know
exactly how to react to it I decided to
place on what provocatively I'm not sure
that's correct but I didn't see anything
wrong with it and he played this Bishop
a 6 move which I wasn't sure like was
completely correct I didn't think it was
bad but in this line of course black
wants his bishop on b7 to play c5 and
put pressure on that that long diagonal
so it was a little bit like different
but I don't know if it was good or bad
per se and then he played this night c5
move which I really didn't expect I mean
I didn't analyze that I had looked at
several other like similar types of
ideas but somehow this move just didn't
come to mind and I think it's a very
strong move because it's hard for me to
react to it because he has these nice
tactics on the D file
yeah okay so yeah here i think was one
like very key point I thought he had a
strong move here b3 where I'm forced to
bring my queen probably back to the back
rank and he can trade rooks play rip d8
and at some point put a piece on d2 and
I thought like there I really could be
like in trouble maybe quite a bit worse
but fortunately for me at least unless I
missed something he didn't play that
move he played this move which I wasn't
really crazy about because I thought he
was like sort of letting me off the hook
in terms of like the pressure he had
then he had the opportunity to play b3
here again which I'm not really sure
what would happen after Queen see one
Queenie five Bishop takes e4 Queen takes
h2 I mean that's like the sort of thing
that only a computer can really answer
probably I mean it or you got to
calculate it for a long long time but it
was certainly something I was worried
about again but then he played this move
and after that I thought I was doing
really really well because all his
pressure was basically dissipated and
now I was going to get to make use of
the fact that his Kings with position
was very weak and here I think I found
like a very very important move because
black has certainly potential threats of
Queen f3 and something that needs to be
contended with that long diagonal but
this move Bishop a6 I think that was
like really the key to my win because he
can't take it because then he gets made
it after Queen takes see 547 so this
force is like the light squared Bishop
soph after which his king is just simply
too weak I think I really don't think he
can defend at this point without like at
least giving me a pawn after which i
don't think the wind should be that hard
for me
and he tried to defend it but mean
pretty clearly like he's going to either
lose two pawns actually or he goes into
this hopeless King and pawn ending and
yeah he realized that and he just gave
up here because it's pretty clear that
the extra pawn in addition to the
outside pawn there's black has no fight
left the international master title is
the second most prestigious in the world
of chess and here you'll see some
familiar names they've been here before
and they're still gunning for that title
hey we still have a long way to go eight
rounds to go remember six and a half
points is the magic number to get that
norm every day the live relay at 11am
and 6 p.m. central time at st. Louis
chess club dot-org